hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world one
of the enemies that we'll be fighting at
this conference is cynicism let's get to
work
the curse against climate controlled
also fast-tracked the future we've done
driverless cars and computer watches but
what's the next big thing in tech in
2016 we're talking to the man who knows
Dateline Paris a hundred and fifty world
leaders from the President of the United
States to the Prime Minister of Tuvalu
have gathered to control climate change
President Obama says the biggest
obstacle is cynicism in a moment we're
talking to Ben Schreiber a senior
environmental lobbyist as usual though
the Democrat commentator Jeffrey
Robinson is standing by for us in New
York and we may be able to hook up with
our regular contributor Armstrong
Williams he's actually traveling by
plane to Las Vegas and may join us later
in the recording
Jeffrey first of all our duty as
citizens to control our use of carbon do
you think it is an imperative I think in
peril is to to light a word I think it
is absolutely critical because if we
blow it we die it's it's that simple
this is a life and death situation
somewhere on the somewhere on the
countdown clock we're at 11:59 I suspect
and it's it's ticking down to doomsday
what I took away from this conference
was the president's remark and I'm
paraphrasing that we are the first
generation to understand the problem and
we will be the last generation who will
be able to do something about it there
is no choice there is no alternative we
have to act and we have to act seriously
and fast well let's bring in Ben Shriver
he's the program director of Friends of
the Earth for us and is actually at the
conference in Paris there's a lot of
optimism when the week began Ben how are
things now so I think that there's a lot
of optimism that we're going to get a
deal in Paris but but going in we've
always known that that whatever happens
here in Paris isn't going to be adequate
to solving the climate crisis this is
one step in a trajectory and so the real
hope is that this moment propels us
forward and continues to shine a real
spotlight on how important and how
imperative it is for us to act now one
of the themes that seems to be emerging
is that it's all very well the Western
sophisticated economies like America
like the UK like France for that matter
preaching to the rest of the world who
are still using coal power don't use so
much carbon but we've had our Industrial
Revolution we've used carbon to get
where we are today there's no question
that you know what is shaping up here in
Paris is very much a dialogue between
the developed in the developing world
and the developed world telling the
developing world that we need you to
help solve this problem that we've
created and the developing world is
saying you know wait a minute we expect
you to finance and help us make the
transition out of poverty in a
sustainable way
and countries like the United States
have refused to do their fair share and
they're refusing to give up the
lifestyle and the the fossil fuels which
still power our economy you know one of
the things that's going to be really
interesting about this conference is
that President Obama came here and he
talked about climate change and he
talked about the imperative but at the
same time the State Department during
this conference is going to be giving
out oil leases and continuing to be
drilling on public lands so we continue
in the United States to be producing
fossil fuels and using them as a basis
of our economy and we need to transition
as well and how difficult is that for
any president Jeffrey do you think let
alone this president in the twilight of
his presidency well it's probably near
impossible for this president because
he's facing a Republican party that
controls the Senate and the house who
deny science I mean these are some
wackos who will tell you with a straight
face
that man walked on the planet at the
same time as dinosaurs they deny science
left right in the Senate Paul Paul Ryan
the Speaker of the House is one of them
and he has said categorically we're not
funding whatever President Obama comes
back with we're not funding it I mean
this is dangerous to the point of
absolute insanity and recklessness we
are playing with the life of the planet
and there will not be a second chance to
get it right if we get it wrong or don't
act that's it game over no I appreciate
you're not a Paul Ryan fan but if if you
were to put the question to him but what
about your grandchildren which seems to
be one of the the things we all
me to reflect on what does he say what
about Paul Ryan's grandchildren he
doesn't care about his grandchildren he
cares about the koch brothers who were
funding him so he can keep getting
reelected and his wacko friends can keep
getting reelected it's the koch brothers
and a few billionaires who want to
pollute the earth because that's where
the profit comes from so they are
funding this whole anti science thing
that climate change doesn't exist we had
chris christie who should know better
because of storm sandy destroying half
the state he was on television this week
saying I just don't believe there's such
a thing as climate change sure the
climate changes four times a year but
real climate change and when he was
faced with the question about rising sea
levels that had climate change not
affected sea levels had there been no
such thing as climate change probably
half the damage that was done wouldn't
have been done but it was done because
the sea levels have risen so much that
the damage of this extraordinary storm
again probably having something to do
with climate change
ruined a huge portion of his state they
simply look at science and the facts and
they deny it and say I don't believe it
it's insanity well Ben's try but this is
such a polarizing issues and it because
of this complication over the science
actually even the scientists are not
completely agreeing we mean Jeffrey
alluded to the storm sandy that may have
come about anyway
might it not irrespective of fossil
fuels being burnt by America and other
nations we need to get past this idea
that weren't worth debating with science
ninety percent ninety nine percent of
the world scientists agree that climate
change is real climate change is
happening and then it's man-made there's
no debate about that we can discuss
whether or not any individual storm
event can be attributed to climate
change and and it is difficult to say
this storm was a result of climate
change or this one is but there's no
question that the world's climate is
changing and we're seeing the impacts
from the droughts in the West in the
United States you know in California to
superstorm sandy and at Hurricane
Katrina and it's impacting real people
here in the United States and across the
world globe there's no question that
climate change is complicated but I
think the real problem is that the
fossil fuel industry doesn't want us to
believe in climate change and
we've seen with these documents that
have been released through Exxon from
Exxon that they've known about climate
change for decades and just like the
tobacco industry was was hiding the
science about smoking they've been
hiding the science about climate change
from the American people and we're only
now you know seeing just how insipid
that has been and how calculated an
effort has been on their part and just
the electorate in America not care about
this Jeffrey well some of them do and
some of them don't the people who are
voting for the GOP wackos who deny
science say no my team is right there is
a debate and we're winning it because
there is no evidence that climate change
exists and for every 100 scientists the
other side produces that says yes it's
real we produce some clown who says no
it's not real in fact so the debate
exists and unfortunately it exists
because the people who hold the purse
strings to change deny science and deny
climate change I I would like to ask Ben
a question then take out your pad and
pencil a number from one to three this
is a test would you please tell me and
everyone else the three irrefutable
arguments that make it absolutely 100
percent understandably that it is
certain and positive that climate change
exists
what are those three arguments that
cannot be refuted even by the
Republicans in the House and Senate I
mean you can't refute that the world's
atmosphere is is the temperatures are
rising
you can't refute the fact that our the
carbon intensity in the world atmosphere
is also rising and it you know is now
above 350 parts per million the level at
which we scientists believe it's going
to be safer would be safe and the
threshold for for keeping temperatures
below 1.5 degrees which is the threshold
that we need and I don't know what the
third that you're alluding to is I don't
know I'm asking you because well I mean
I think the third is we're seeing the
the the real weather events here the
strange weather all offense the wacky
weather you know the droughts in
California the wildfires the her
Katrina's these are events that we
haven't had with the frequency that we
have before I mean I'm sitting here in
Paris and it's incredibly warm right now
and yes that happens every once in a
while but we're having outlier events
outlier weather events frequently and
all the time and it's having a real
impact on on people on crops on our
economy okay let me Jeffery and let me
try and understand here get into the
American psyche we all know that fossil
fuels have a finite they are finite okay
so at some point in the great American
nation someone's going to actually say
I've got to put a different kind of fuel
in my car or have a different kind of
fuel I'm going to have to power my
factory by some other way I'm going to
have to generate electricity new ways
and you know that is now in the
foreseeable future does that argument
never gain any traction with policy
makers well it gains traction on the two
coasts where you've got people who are
willing to admit that yes climate change
is real in the middle of the country
especially in the in in the Republican
South they won't admit it because the
politicians whom they're sending to the
house and the Senate who have the purse
strings absolutely denied one of the
things that happened I mean California
is always ahead of everybody else one of
the things that happened several years
ago when they realized that pollution
levels were getting so terrible in
California was they said tell you what
if you buy a hybrid car so that you can
save on fossil fuels if you buy a hybrid
car we will let you park for free in Los
Angeles so today if you have a hybrid or
if you have an electric car not just a
Tesla but of any others there are
electric pumps all over Los Angeles we
can park in charge or you can just
simply park it a meter for free if
you've got a hybrid that's helping to
move the indicator a little bit closer
to where it should be but you know it
doesn't happen in the rest of the states
it happens in California because
everything starts there it may happen
soon in New York I hope it does but it's
the rest of the world it's the rest of
what we call the flyover States who
we're saying no I want my big gas
guzzler car even if you tell me I
shouldn't have it and I want to heat my
home properly and
I don't really care because the Koch
brothers are great guys and they're
getting me the politicians I deserve let
me just ask Ben about let's
internationalize this a bit in
particular focus on India because the
Indian delegation I think in Paris have
said look you're just being unfair on us
our economy needs to grow it needs
energy to grow and coal is probably the
best way we can generate energy they
kind of have a point then they've been
so the Indian delegation definitely has
a point you know the United States and
the developed world caused this problem
they have we have brought the world to
the precipice of this crisis and we're
saying wait a minute now we all need to
lock arms and and fight this problem
together
and they're saying wait a minute you've
gotten wealthy off this you've gotten
rich off this and and what are you
saying that we need to make changes in
our lifestyle in our society in order to
deal with this problem that you've
created that said they also shouldn't be
and can't be developing with coal what
we need is we need to have our countries
the United States and the developed
world giving them the renewable energy
the solar power the wind the technology
so that they can develop on a better
trajectory and it's not like fossil
fuels don't have costs associated with
them aside from from just the climate
impacts you know these are these are
fuels that cause asthma not to cause
lung disease that cause cancer these are
fuels that kill people they kill the
people that live near those plants and
near those facilities that live near the
mines and so we do have the opportunity
for a better society for a better
development model but the developed
world actually has to help the
developing world move forward on a
different trajectory than the one that
we did it and right now we're refusing
to do that the amount of climate finance
that we have to do they're not of money
that the United States is willing to pay
to help India develop in a different way
is terribly inadequate Ben Schreiber
good to have you with us today thank you
thanks for having me
now reminder you can catch up with the
Sky News debate on Apple TV on roku and
catch up and of course at Sky News com /
us now who would have thought that in
1970 the must have new piece of
technology was the video cassette
recorder ten years later in 1981 it was
a compact disc player and in 2001 it saw
the introduction of the plasma TV in the
last 12 months the driverless car has
progressed at pretty good speed and the
computer watch has gone on sale
well Gary Shapiro is the president and
CEO of the Consumer Electronics
Association he also wrote the
best-selling book the comeback how
innovation will restore the American
Dream and Geoffrey Robinson of course is
still with us as well Gary let's go to
you first we're getting ready for your
big show haven't we the CES show in
January what do you think of the big
themes gonna come up next year well yes
yes we'll be in Las Vegas in January it
is the largest size we've ever had it
we're actually restricting attendance so
it's not too crowded in hotel rates will
not be too high but the themes will be
innovation everything there's no one big
breakout product the story really is
that innovation is happening everywhere
with driverless cars robotics 3d
printing with virtual reality with
augmented reality with home technology
and controls with so many different
areas that are exploding we're seeing it
with drones we're seeing it with 3d
printing and we're seeing with wireless
health technology many many different
areas and in the startup world is
exploding we'll have over 500 companies
in what we call Eureka Park with a
waiting list which is actually a curated
area just for startups so what we're
seeing is a phenomenal wave of
innovation in many many different
categories that are providing a world
which is solving major problems major
problems in energy use in healthcare and
food production and education and of
course there's a lots of entertainment
just give me the sort of hit rate guide
me on that if you're a startup yesterday
citing time to be around because you
have your chance you may just make it
but on the other hand there's probably
dozens if not hundreds of people doing
something similar so how many really do
break through and be a success a
shockingly large number actually there's
a tremendous amount of investment money
available for in the technology world
because as recently as the climate
change summit we're talking about
technology and innovation as being the
solutions to the world's problems we're
talking about the biggest problems in
the world it's just not energy use is
just hunger it's food production it's
clean water it's clean air it's disease
it's education it's so many different
things and what we are in is phenomenal
time period in history which has never
occurred before where anyone who can
basically spend the money on some simple
device like a smartphone or a computer
or a tablet and have wireless or
broadband access they can come up with
something which will solve problems so
the barriers to entry are low and the
tools are there and the tools frankly
are these micro electromechanical system
these MEMS which are simply devices
sensors which are in every smartphone
they they measure where you are they're
gyroscopes and accelerometers and
pressure and temperature they measure
many different things and they cost a
few pennies apiece and very clever
people are putting them together in
really unique ways and they're solving
problems and that's what the Internet of
Things really is you take these tiny
tiny little devices and you hook them up
with each other and all of a sudden you
have solutions to many problems they
have to do with security and safety
we're going to in the next decade or two
we're gonna cut down dramatically on the
world's car accidents and and traffic
and and and use of fuel why because of
these devices and the wireless internet
and smart innovators around the world
and it's a lot of them will make it big
already we're seeing what we call these
unicorns that are out there these are
billion dollar valuation companies and
we're just startups or didn't exist just
five years ago and I think on the list
of única 100 unicorns about 15 or 20 of
them just didn't even exist as companies
five years ago so there's still
opportunities for new companies to
really break out in Korean zillionaires
not
that's the goal but the goal is really
to allow innovation to solve problems
and for bright people to come up and and
show the creative juice and show they
what they can do and let the marketplace
determine which wins Geoffrey what are
you here Gary taught like that it's
exciting time to be a technologist it's
the exciting time to be an innovator
isn't it absolutely there has never been
and garish boroughs absolutely right
there has never been a more exciting
time on this planet back in the I guess
in the 70s there was a book as I
remember I think was called the greening
of America that spoke about the fact
that there were more scientists alive on
the planet at that time then there had
been cumulatively throughout history and
I'm sure that's true today I'm sure
there are more scientists and
technologists alive today than there
have ever been added up from the from
the beginning of mankind one of the
things that is always absolutely
fascinated me is all of the toys we use
today the the smartphones and the
laptops and and all of the various toys
we use today by the year 2025 we will
have new toys that will replace our old
toys and of the 20-25 toys that we will
depend on something like 90 or 95
percent of them have not yet been
invented this is an extremely exciting
time where we are connecting with people
around the world just as we're doing now
for free I might add on skype being able
to see and do and research and talk to
and solve all sorts of problems I did a
little bit of AI did a little bit of
research here and in 2010 the US Patent
Office had four hundred ninety thousand
applications for patents and that year
is significant because the television
program Shark Tank started in 2009 so
one year into Shark Tank there were four
hundred ninety thousand applications
five years after the beginning of Shark
Tank which is a fabulously popular
program it has increased to six hundred
and fifteen thousand which is an
increase of 25% and I looked at all of
the years previously we have never in
the five-year period had as much an
increase in patent applications and now
I suspect there is a cause and result
maybe Gary can talk to that
the fact that innovation comes to us so
easily it's just there and what you have
to do is figure out the better mousetrap
and all of the the ways of making it
work are easily obtainable let me just
throw that to Gary and also the thought
that it doesn't really know innovation
that is no borders does it if you've got
the right idea
and those modest resources you alluded
to anyone can have this idea you don't
have to be at a posh American University
absolutely that is the case innovation
knows no borders but there are things
that governments can do to help or hurt
innovation I've written two books about
innovation at several hundred columns
you know that you talk about patent
applications which is which is the
measure we sometimes used to describe
innovation it's a really lousy measure
honestly for example in China China's
had a huge surge in the number of patent
applications why because of their
five-year plan they have a goal of a
certain number of patents for a hundred
thousand people so they're putting in a
lot of week and variations on a theme
patents and we even seen a little bit of
that in the United States but still that
is a good measure but what we also need
you need Cubbies are willing to invest I
think the u.s. is blessed with
investment investors and they often
congregate in areas and all times
there's also you have to be willing to
fail and that there's a culture in the
United States and in Israel that failure
is education it's not a it's not a bad
thing there's also a culture among our
sculptures and asking why and rather
than learning by rote and that's
important there's also tremendous
diversity in the US and that I think is
beneficial to invention especially in
larger companies but yes anyone with an
idea can and does often do really great
things and it doesn't require a huge
capital investment if you're especially
if you're talking about the next cool
app or the next Facebook or something
like that it's really a software
solution which just requires an idea and
some really good app writers and
execution on it and then you'll attract
investment Geoffrey yeah let me ask Gary
let's say tomorrow morning I wake up
with an idea for a better mousetrap what
do I do
well it depends what it is I am a big
believer in not writing a lengthy
business plan that you go at you expose
it to potential customers and get their
input that's what we weave divine design
our entire trade show around that's what
your Rica Park is with the 500 startups
is you for like almost nothing we
subsidize it you basically go there and
you get a lot of feedback very quickly
but you don't have to do that at a trade
show you could you could go visit
customers you could do it with the
public you could do with friends but
just start start and sometimes you have
to move very quickly and that's another
thing that governments sometimes affect
they make it difficult to start a
business you have a license you have to
get broadband lines there's rules on
hiring and what you hire you can't fire
that's inconsistent with innovation so
having a flexible work force having a
government that makes a difference but
going out there and of course it
requires money you have to be able to
sell your idea one of the I've judged a
lot of events I deal with a lot of
investors and big companies and small
and one of the challenges is you might
have a great idea and you have a person
who can't speak or execute or can't lead
or manage and you need a you need to
complement your you know who you are
know what your weaknesses are and get
some people around you who complement
those weaknesses with their strengths
and put a team together that could
really make a difference and that
requires can I can I just ask you about
the whole idea though if trade shows I
mean as you say the CES is one of the
biggest I think America does but it's
isn't it a bit of a quaint anachronism
that we still in 2016 fly people from
all over the world to one set of hotels
in Las Vegas where they bump into one
another or is there something about that
that's still very important even in the
days of Kickstarter and the web and the
instant video job is to be a cheerleader
for the technology industry and in
theory technology will say we don't need
any of this we could just have video
conference calls and we could do that
but the reality is we're human being
still and that human experience of
looking some in the eye figuring out
whether you trust them using your five
senses to see how companies position
themselves is very valuable and we all
need it as human beings to be in touch
face-to-face with each other I love this
all this technology stuff but you know
what I wanna I want to be with people
that's who I am
and I enjoy the human touch the contact
the hug the handshake and that matters
and there's
the value of serendipity how do you have
serendipity in a world online world is a
serious question even today and with a
tradeshow you could go from one exhibit
to another and see how the company wants
to position themselves you can see the
people there you could see the products
you could compare them immediately and
from a green perspective it actually
makes a lot of sense because the average
person going to a tradeshow has like 12
to 20 meetings they save several hundred
thousand miles and trips around the
world the CEO of Intel Brian krzanich
thanked me on the fourth day of the CES
and said what you think of me you're
here on the fourth day said oh my god
this is amazing since I do more in these
four days and see more people that I can
possibly do in the first few months of
the year and you said thank you for
having this event let me know how I
could help you
and that's not uncommon because it is
very efficient and we've designed this
event not only for for exhibits but also
so the leaders in innovation around the
world can get together in one place from
many different industries it's the
automobile entertainment industry
advertising industry content creation
broadcasting satellite and others all in
one location and business has done and
what's really changed radically in just
the last few years even is the value of
going across industries to cut deals
which make a difference you have to be
able to team up and go out of your
vertical space and meet with other
people and do something and that's where
a lot of innovation is coming is people
in different disciplines getting
together and I think that's what
universities are starting to figure out
and work on the value of an MBA now is
teamwork more than anything else and
knowing your skills and knowing who else
you need and putting it together and
working together as a team which is
really valued now at the CEO level
around the world how do you characters
Geoffrey I'm sorry we we've got to wrap
it here so let me just say thank you
just a second and Gary Shapiro thank you
so much for being with us today and
Geoffrey thank you for joining us from
New York and that's it for this edition
of the debate you can continue watching
sky news on apple TV on roku and catch
up and of course on sky news calm until
next time goodbye
you